never just xbg we have a press that just
gives them a free pass the boys were
caught after setting the homeless man on
fire a tumor this size is very dangerous
do you have any family oh hey creepy
wasn't the schoolgirl thing a little
played out don't make it so if you want
the car just taken my parents got me the
wrong one anyways yeah that's a [ __ ]
tragedy did you just kill Chloe else
really rips my [ __ ] off to her - we Andy
will be used stars and magic didn't you
call their tits the girly one who was
crystals
you're aiming at the bear right this is
the best day ever
[Music]
Frank don't let me I'm recording this
thanks for turning off your cell phone
you're welcome
why have a civilization if we no longer
interested in being civilized
hey buddy la lot of crazy people out
there I'm gonna want to kill people who
deserve to die we gonna do this or what
no it's not normal to want to kill but I
am no longer normal take both those
spots yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you